Think you know everything about the force?
Here's 29 Star Wars facts you probably don't know.
It's a trap!
Alec Guinness called the Star Wars films fairy tale rubbish.
Despite this he earned 2% of the gross box office receipts for the original trilogy.
Making him over 95 million dollars.
In my experience there's no such thing as luck.
Harrison Ford earned only 2,000 dollars a week for his role in episode 4.
10,000 all in advance.
Peter Cushing found his costume boots so uncomfortable he wore slippers during many of his scenes.
And insisted his feet never be shown.
The TIE fighter engine sound is an elephant call mixed with a car driving on wet pavement.
While shooting this scene Mark Hamill held his breath so long he burst a blood vessel on the side of his face.
Many of the Tatooine sets are still standing today in the Tunisian desert.
Denis Lawson who played Wedge Antilles is Ewan McGregor's uncle.
The blockade runner was the original design for the Millennium Falcon.
The Jawa language is based on a sped up version of the Zulu language.
Greedo speaks a South American language called Quechua.
Yoda's species is never named in the movies.
The word Ewok is never said out loud in any of the films.
The original design of Yoda was a monkey carrying a cane and wearing a mask.
The bounty hunter droid IG-88 was built from recycled film props.
His head is a drink dispenser from the Mos Eisley Cantina.
In an early draft of Jedi, Obi Wan and Yoda returned to their physical bodies to either assist Luke in his final battle with the emperor
Or join him during the celebration on Endor.
No physical clone trooper outfits were ever produced.
Every clone trooper scene in the prequels is CGI.
Qui-Gon's communicator is an altered Gillette Sensor Excel women's razor.
According to Samuel L. Jackson the words "bad mother f***er" are engraved on the hilt of his lightsaber.
During fight scenes an excited Ewan McGegor kept making lightsaber sounds.
Ahmed Best who played Jar Jar Binks can be seen out of character in the background of this scene.
Along with Anthony Daniels who plays C-3P0.
The Galactic Empire symbol is hidden in this shot of Anakin.
Anakin Skywalker meets six of the nine diagnostic criteria for borderline personality disorder.
In an early draft of episode IV, RD-D2 speaks standard english and is actually kind of a jerk.
The phrase "I have a bad feeling about this" is said at least once in every film.
I have a bad feeling about this.
An Island called Niue minted and accepts Star Wars coins as currency.
8 different people have played Darth Vader.
David Prowse
James Earl Jones
Bob Anderson
Sebastian Shaw
Jake Lloyd
Hayden Christensen
Matt Lanter
and Matt Lucas
And finally a disco version of the Star Wars theme became a number one hit in 1977.
How many facts did you already know?